there's an old saying always be yourself
unless you can be Batman I'm Batman but
not everyone who's considered for the
role of Batman gets the chance and not
everyone who's offered the chance
actually takes it over the years a lot
of stars have been considered for the
role of the Caped Crusader for both
television and film and a lot of fans
have been left wondering what might have
been here's a look at some actors who
were almost cast as Batman Kelly and
Murphy for his 2005 reboot Batman Begins
director Christopher Nolan saw as many
as a dozen up-and-coming actors among
them was Irish actor in 28 days later
star Killian Murphy he recalls having an
awkward audition and screen test in
which he read his lines while wearing a
complete Batman suit he didn't get that
part but no one was impressed enough
with his performance that he cast him in
Batman Begins as the Scarecrow seems
like a pretty good choice Josh Hartnett
Josh Hartnett was one of the actors no
one considered early on to star in
Batman Begins
but Hartnett one of the biggest young
male stars of the early 2000s pulled his
own name from consideration out of fears
he would be typecast as a superhero a
decision he told playboy that he greatly
regrets now watching Christian Bale go
on to do so many other things that's
been just awesome I mean he's been able
to overcome that why couldn't I see that
at the time armie hammer in 2007 Warner
Brothers was all set to film a Justice
League movie and now they already had a
Batman the form of Christian Bale
director George Miller decided to cast
someone else in the role at someone
Armie Hammer three years before his
breakout appearance in the social
network Justice League ended up being
scrapped due to the Writers Guild of
America strike which Hammer told Yahoo
movies he's actually grateful for I
would have made a terrible Batman really
terrible it's too young no one wants to
see a 19 year old Batman what could a 19
year old do it'd be like his parents had
just been shot last weekend Josh Brolin
but No Country for Old Men and Jonah Hex
star met with Man of Steel director Zack
Snyder but it was decided that the plans
for the next Superman movie would
include Superman fighting the Dark
Knight after that concept morphed into
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
Snyder and Brolin ultimately both
decided it wasn't a good fit and Brolin
moved on to the Marvel Universe as their
ultimate boogeyman Thanos West Bentley
as Batman vs Superman took shape former
Batman boss Christopher Nolan suggested
his interest teller star West Bentley
for the
best known for American Beauty The
Hunger Games and American Horror Story
on TV Bentley ultimately was passed over
what do you mean
instead Ben Affleck got the role poor
Ben
Bill Murray it sounds crazy but back in
the mid-80s Ghostbusters director Ivan
Reitman was amongst a handful of
directors considered by Warner Brothers
to develop a big-screen vehicle for
Batman right ones choice for the lead
role Ghostbuster star Bill Murray with
Eddie Murphy reportedly in the running
is Robin but the comic book version of
Batman enjoying a revival thanks to grim
and gritty stories like The Dark Knight
Returns though Warner Brothers
ultimately opted against the community
out in favor of Tim Burton's dark and
manic vision pierce brosnan the future
James Bond was on director Tim Burton's
short list of the role of The Dark
Knight in his 1989 film version of
Batman but as the actor explained in a
reddit AMA he met with Burton and just
couldn't see himself in the role because
he thought it was all rather silly
saying any man who wears his underpants
outside his pants just cannot be taken
seriously and it would be a shame for
Brosnan to do anything that couldn't be
taken seriously
not to mention how preposterous the
Batmobile is right ray liotta ray liotta
had just starred in his first movie
something wild in 1986 when his agent
got a call saying Tim Burton was
interested in auditioning him for lead
role of Batman he declined even the
chance to meet with burden something he
says he still regrets don't feel too
sorry for Liotta though he opted to make
the oscar-nominated classic Goodfellas
instead Alec Baldwin no less a film
authority than Quentin Tarantino once
said that alec baldwin would have made a
great batman in the 1980s and it almost
happened like Pierce Brosnan Baldwin was
being considered for Tim Burton's Batman
having worked with the director in his
previous movie beetlejuice
but another Beetlejuice star Betelgeuse
himself Michael Keaton wound up with the
part making Baldwin one of the ultimate
what-ifs in Batman history here I give a
professional he did get a consolation
prize though a lead role in the 1994
flop the shadow which he's still trying
to get people to forget William Baldwin
when both director Tim Burton and star
Michael Keaton opted did not return with
the third Batman movie new director Joel
Schumacher was hired to helm Batman
Forever and he brought along his own
ideas about who should star his choices
ray Fiennes Daniel day-lewis Val Kilmer
and William Billy Baldwin Alex younger
brother a quick question jack our
underwear is it regular black bikini cut
or is it silk boxers with Tweety Bird on
him because I have both Baldwin audition
for Schumacher who told him that he'd
been the first choice but that Warner
Brothers executives preferred Val Kilmer
Billy eventually got his day in the Sun
voicing Batman for several animated
projects
to this
pack ass
you blinked David Duchovny like Michael
Keaton before him Val Kilmer walked away
from the cape and cowl after Batman
forever can I persuade you to take a
sandwich with you so I'll get drive-thru
Warner Brothers had to scramble to find
an actor to star in 1997's Batman and
Robin the choice came down to two
emerging TV stars George Clooney of ER
and David Duchovny of the x-files
Clooney ultimately got the role and
promptly put the franchise into a
decade-long deep freeze
maybe you melted no he's just
hibernating looks like Duchovny had the
last laugh Lyle Waggoner finally no
Batman list would be complete without a
look at the 1966 TV series when ABC was
putting together the can't be classic
producers looked at potential Batman and
Robin's as duo's holy multitude the
final two options came down to Lyle
Waggoner and Peter Dayal or Adam West
and Burt Ward West and Ward got the
parts of course while Wagner went on to
co-star on The Carol Burnett Show who
knows how this one would have turned out
if Wagner had won the role the show
might have bombed some days you just
can't get rid of a bomb thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which of these stars
would have made the best Batman